make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
and you guys say that I don't read the
YouTube comments in my videos jab one
four three five this guy has been asking
that sounds like a run jab one four
three five this guy has been asking for
the same video for like the last five
months he's been asking for the same
video strange visitors Superman beyond
omega-level I feel like this guy's gonna
be like just now I'm gonna ask for more
stuff here's a funny thing I didn't even
know who this guy was I was like man who
the hell even is strange visitors
Superman like does he like visit another
planet and people are just like this
guy's strange and he's visiting us so
he's a strange visitor I didn't know
dude this guy is Opie it's not even
funny it's he's ridiculously powerful
strange visitor Superman versus dr.
Manhattan is a video that we need to do
on our vs. videos for patreon those guys
who don't know we do vs. videos all the
time on patreon like this week is
taskmaster vs. Deathstroke because you
guys voted for it I'll let you guys
decide you just like what do you guys
want to see and you guys were like
Deathstroke versus taskmaster and I was
like really the week before that you
guys chose condiment King versus kite
man I was like what is even going on
right now it's crazy
anyway this version of Superman was
created by a joke Keaton I think is how
you pronounce his name and Britt shoot
over and made his first and only
appearance in Adventures of Superman
number 16 in October of 2014 now just to
clarify in case you want to read this
story Adventures of Superman was a
digital first comic there was later
released and print as issue number 16 of
the series but if you're looking to get
this on comiXology
uh the story actually occurs in issues
number forty-six through 48 and digital
format and this series was designed to
let creators tell one shot Superman
stories without worrying about what
effect their stories would have on the
overall continuity of Superman right so
like DC you but without messing
everything up the story titled strange
visitor opens up many years in the
future with a character named Kamandi
recounting the story of Superman to
another individual named rad ffice uh
who is identified as the boy king in
America in Earth's final hour
the story begins just outside metropolis
in 1939 with Superman fighting some of
Frankenstein's monsters alongside Batman
and Dracula the next day he attends the
launch of a manned spacecraft from the
tropics and we learned that the
existence of super me
has inspired humanity to innovate at a
rate much faster than they otherwise
would have as evidenced by the fact that
the first real manned spaceflight didn't
occur until 1961 but here it's happening
22 years ahead of that we also learned
that the spacecraft is being powered by
red kryptonite shards of Superman's home
planet that had been altered to serve as
a fuel source
soon after the rocket called the Phaeton
blasts off things begin to go awry as
they usually do
Superman leaps into action but is unable
to save the crew before the ship
seemingly vanishes into thin air now the
crew is presumed dead but Superman
believes that since the spacecraft
vanished rather than exploded that he
can still save the crew of the faith on
which will continue to drive him
throughout his entire life now from here
Superman's life proceeds and pretty much
the exact same way that we're familiar
with he's a superhero he falls in love
with Lois Lane all the regular stuff
however while everyone is Superman's
universe ages normally he ages at a much
slower rate so by the time 2013 rolls
around we see this Superman is
practically unchanged since 1939 but
Lois Lane is an old woman is also around
this time that the 75th anniversary of
Superman's superhero career is being
commemorated by the dedication of a
massive statue of him at the metropolis
spaceport the same place that the
Phaeton had vanished 74 years prior now
with everyone gathered at the ceremony
the entire Justice League the old and
new God and a massive crowd in
Metropolis citizens this statue comes to
life and reveals itself to actually be
mr. Mixel pedelec the fifth-dimensional
empties been a nuisance to Superman
his whole career now Mixel pedelec takes
superman to the fifth dimension and
tells him that he wants to give him a
gift and reveals to him that the faith
on had not actually been destroyed
validating what superman had believed
for decades unfortunately the ship is
unreachable even from the fifth
dimension but is instead trapped between
realities in an unstable state and so
Superman is unable to reach the ship
that day but vows that he will find a
way to one day rescue the crew of the
faith on we then fast-forward billions
and billions of years into the future
far past the events of Kamandi & Wraith
Otis leaving earth to set up a
civilization somewhere in space to the
final moments of the universe itself
we've seen the Superman has been able to
spawn multiple copies of himself which
he calls Superman centuries one of these
centuries referred to as Superman 2099
no pun intended is attending the death
of the God on
who is worshipped by the supreme deity
of the ancient Mesopotamians now once on
you dies we learned that he was actually
the last living entity in the entire
universe other than Superman himself
following this death the original
Superman called Superman null summons
all the centuries that he can reunite
into a singular entity we also learned
that Superman null has been at the
center of the entire universe and was
actually holding the whole universe
together waiting for the last living
thing to pass away before he would allow
the universe to be destroyed now once
all the centuries and Superman Nova
unites the resulting Superman is visited
by the memory of Lois Lane who says that
she's there to see him off as the
universe meets its end now before it
does however Superman manages to locate
the faith on and rips through the very
fabric of reality to pull the ship out
the crew remarked that they believe
they've been gone for merely five
minutes but Superman and we as the
readers know that it's actually been
billions of years with the ship rescued
Superman escorts it to the very edge of
the universe where he assures them that
they will enter a new universe and he
will never abandon them and that's where
the story ends and this is all we know
about strange visitors Superman he
appears to be the in continuity version
of Superman in every way right down to
his vulnerability to kryptonite
however for whatever reason which is
never explained this version of Superman
is essentially immortal outliving
every life-form and every God and the
universe now during the billions of
years that he exists he grows vastly
more powerful we see that he's able to
divide himself into multiple beings all
of which seemingly share his powers and
is able to communicate with them
telepathically he's able to tear through
the barrier of reality and possessed
enough strength and willpower to hold
the universe together for an untold and
unimaginable number of years which means
he probably made for a pretty decent
Green Lantern so we are definitely
dealing with one of the most powerful
iterations of Superman that we've ever
seen and is definitely well beyond
omega-level as he appears to be the
single most powerful entity and his
entire universe so yeah that's basically
it there's really nothing more to it
than that
but we covered it you guys wanted to see
it so we covered it uh yeah so if you
guys are new here to comment explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoyed this video or you drop a like
and I will catch you all later peace
okay I want to give a shout out to Kyle
be David Joseph bin john h aj matt in
Jeff are John H lean and mean which is
an awesome name Jason see Austin s
Austin Asia Joey M Steven Z Austin be
Adam K and Genesis 9 16 remember guys
you get to me messages and I'll run off
whatever your message is at the end of
the video so long there's nothing crazy
but if you want to put a message in
there send me an email Rob at Robert
Jefferson calm and if you're one of
these people who get shoutouts
then I will tack it in there and yeah
they should watch it guys
[Music]